key afternoon members Cara have we got
the public on stream Cara you're new
today
I'm sorry tourniquets we do everyone
thank you good afternoon and welcome to
the council meeting on Thursday the 16th
of July 2020
my name is councillor Bob Boyce and I am
the chairman of the Morden district
counts the meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect on
the 4th of April in response to the
tobik 19 situation there are a few
housekeeping issues to run through
including a new working practices which
have been implemented due to the
pandemic and the etiquette for this
meeting first of all please could I ask
everyone present in this meeting to
ensure your microphones remain muted and
your video feed off when now not
addressing the committee the council
this will reduce background noises and
avoid any unintentional disturbances the
meeting will be hosted remotely via
conference software which allows members
of the public to virtually attend the
meeting whilst being able to protect
themselves and others and observe the
government's lockdown measures we are
streaming this meeting live as well as
recorded and by being present in the
meeting you are given your consent to
being recorded members and officers
during each item please use the chat
function of the meeting to indicate if
you wish to speak or they invite you at
the appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating your wish to speak what you
have to leave the meeting the chat
function should be used for anything
other purpose members the process this
afternoon will obviously be different
and for some items I may invite each
member to speak and therefore I really
encourage all members to keep your
contribution as clear and concise as
possible please really invited to speak
please ensure you turn off on your
microphone and camera when speaking is
referring to the agenda papers please
ensure your reference a page or
paragraph number
Kalai also ensure that everyone is
directly connected to a power supply so
that nobody drops out due to short
battery life we may encounter some
glitches this afternoon so I hope that
everyone will bear with us as we get
used to this new way of working and
lastly if members need to leave the
meeting at any point for the eastin make
this known and use the chat function to
signify that you need to leave the
meeting our now our some officers taking
part in the meeting to introduce
themselves and I'll start with mr. Han's
good afternoon members Richard Holmes
director of service delivery thank you
[Music]
good afternoon members Paul Dodson
director of strategy performance and
governance good afternoon
Chris Leslie director of resources
afternoon Simon Quelch monitoring
officer good afternoon
Matthew Lee lead specialist place good
afternoon
Jackie Longman strategy theme lead place
[Music]
mr. butcher good afternoon Steven
butchered commercial manager I think
he's on line yet
okay mrs. Holmes again I think she's
joining us later chairman okay and mr.
Thompson might also be joining us later
if he's not already present miss Byrd
Thank You tarantara birds
I'm the committee cup for this meeting
thank you very much now Tara is there
any other officers present that you know
of at this time and know Tammy not that
I'm aware of thank you
let's go on to agenda item 2 then
apologies for absence I think so so
white is having difficulty getting on
she turned it to log on in a remote area
so I'll send her apologies yes gone
after you barking okay well we'll we'll
sort that out later I think at this
stage of go to Chairman's announcements
we haven't done members roll call all
right
please can we do the roll call the
antara
thank you chairman members if you could
just confirm if you're present please
and starting with councillor Bamford
please yes on present Laura Thank You
councillor Basinger that's the passenger
so miss Beale present Thank You caps of
broadly
cat Sibel present counsel mrs. chana
hello Tara president pinky Council of
Durham a chairman of the council Durham
has given his apologies he will be
attending a little late he's stuck in
another meeting
okay councillor Edwards Council Edwards
sir mrs. Fleming present terram cats the
Flickr president thank you
cats the haka president Dhara that's the
head present or present Tara counselor
home present Tara
that's a Jarvis present thanks Tara
please that's okay present thank you
thank you very much cancel again I can
confirm my own presence thank you very
much
cats amazed present Tara that's the
morning yeah so Morris
that's an awesome meal cancer lung
cancer shaughnessy present Turin Asus
it'll good afternoon taro present means
good afternoon everybody
hi mr. chairman Tara members I'm present
cancer stilts cancer swain capsule mrs.
Thompson I'm I'm present Tara and but I
won't be able to use video cuz I haven't
got a very good broadband connection so
you'd be able to hear me but not see me
hopefully thank you thank you and
Katherine is white so I'm not so Helen
I'm going to be in or out but at the
moment I'm here I looked in four times
already thanks okay thank you very much
Thank You chairman Thank You Tara now
I'm going to go to Chairman's
announcements and it's a great sadness I
announce the passing of only six what
needless the best Obi who has in the
past being the leader of this authority
and has been chairman of it twice Rodney
has spent 40 years with the serving
people of this district as a district
councillor and as of his ability and his
conduct of business should be a an
example for us all
and I said severely mourn his passing he
was a friend a colleague and a mentor of
mine and I would ask members
for a few moments silence and
contemplation on their life and the good
works of Rodney Bess
can we now go back to agenda item three
declaration of interests to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interest other pecuniary
interest or number QE interests relating
to items of business on the agenda and
having regard to the paragraph six to
the light inclusive the code of conduct
for members become aware so the need
arise throughout the meeting if any
member has an interest to declare please
use the chat function now to indicate
and will invite you to speak I've got
mrs. chana and mrs. Chan Asad father
this is China
Thank You chairman chairman I'd like to
declare my non-pecuniary interest as a
member of the six County Council for any
item on the agenda that may relate to
Essex County Council in any way or
manacle obviously we do work often with
Essex County Council so I'm just
covering any aspect chairman Thank You
councillor maze
yes Thank You chairman yes I'd like to
disclose a non-pecuniary interest in
item 10 as I'm a ward member from Alton
north item 11 as I'm on the working
group and I 219 for a personal matter
thank you thank you tarah is there
anybody else and no chairman nobody else
thank you very much thank you very much
then I then can go to the minutes agenda
item for the minutes of the 2nd of July
2020 and contained on pages 7 to 16 and
I am asking their approval as a true
accurate record I'm sorry the minutes
chairman I have got an amendment a
matter of accuracy please
please let me have it what page and
where is it it's page 8 chairman yep and
it speaks about the notice of motion
it's just it's just the last part of
four and it said council area misheard
advise the in respect of okay your
middle on the middle line it should it
should read the council waives the
overall political control but it's got
ways you've got that thank you I think I
counsel the Darrin mule joined us you
have a declaration to make yes apologies
chairman I will just declare the usual
bumpkin interest as a member of Essex
County Council and that interest covers
anything pertaining to Essex on the
agenda today thank you I come to agenda
item six again Chairman's announcements
I just wish to add that I attended the
Civic Center at chance word this week on
the launch of the new CCTV system that's
operating in Malden and I was very
impressed and I'm sure members will be
getting some information from the
communication team at some time in the
future thank you I now move on to agenda
item seven the minute book performance
an audit committee and can I ask the
chairman of that committee councillor
Bamford to present the minutes please
councillor Banford
Thank You chairman I will say these have
not been approved by the committee
itself so these minutes are on pages
three to 12 of the modpack
it's for the PGA performance governance
an audit committee that was held on the
25th of June should I go through page by
page chairman three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve is that
agreed noted goji berry three great
questions in accordance with procedure
around six three at which notice has
been given
I have no there's no questions been
received so we go on to agenda item ten
and action plan can I ask the League two
percent this
[Music]
Thank You chairman leaders yeah Thank
You chairman just to let you know you're
you're breaking up quite badly so
whether or not you want to turn off your
video feed III don't know but chairman
before I give way to missus Longman to
present this report can I can I pay
tribute to her and her team on behalf of
all members for the enormous amount work
that's gone into this document there has
been a lot of work we've been through
two consultations and in my mind it
really does reflect the hard work that's
gone on
so chairman with your permission I'll
give way to missus long manner and then
perhaps you'll come back to me with
regards to the recommendations Thank You
missus Longman Thank You chairman so the
policy s five of the LVP and the camp
project to seek to retain the market
tell focus of Morden's entire high
street and highlight the need to
increase footfall and improve the retail
offer at the lower high street support
generation and diversification of the
town center including the evening
economy and encourage sustainable travel
the lower highest reaction plan has
seven actions to realize the potential
of the lower high streets sustain the
vitality and vibrancy of the whole high
street and encourage a diverse town
center economy the seven actions have
been reviewed by local key stakeholders
and businesses set out in appendix two
and have been further reviewed through
the reset and recoveries response to
Kovach 19 that has galvanized and
mobilized community and business support
for the high street recovery at both
district and county levels and with the
advice from the government's high street
task force action one sets up a high
street focus group led by the council to
champion the best interests of the whole
high strength to achieve the LD policy
s5 the overarching master plan
objectives and the high street reset and
recoveries response - Kovach 19 actions
2 to 7 addressed the opportunities and
challenges identified in the town center
and on the high street including actions
take account of changes that may arise
from the air quality management area on
Market Hill I have back to you chairman
oh thank you mrs. Longman leader would
you like to come back on this yeah Thank
You chairman I've got I've got some
speakers noted but I'd wondered whether
you wanted to say anything before we
hear speakers well chairman I will go to
the recommendations and propose chairman
that council agrees recommendation 1 and
counts or agrees recommendation 2
chairman but I think there's a typo in
there I think we need to remove the word
of that the council endorses of it
doesn't really quite make sense so I
think we need to change that chairman or
at least delete that word and with
two recommendations three Chairman I
would propose that the two members
appointed to the group the focus group
are councillor Fleming chairman and
councilor none thank you thank you
second second second did Thompson thank
you now the first speaker I've got was
councilor Banford
followed by councillor heard council
back okay thank you
Thank You chairman just to say this is
very welcome but my emphasis want you to
be on market because mold and is a
market town so I have been on the market
working group before and we have looked
at the lower high street for the market
and I wouldn't want that the fact that
we need to keep a market in Molden to be
overlooked with this heist lower high
street strategy and also the town centre
strategy which is mentioned on page 34
where it does mention improvements to by
playing car park so really to just
emphasize please that we don't forget
that moden is a market town and we need
to retain a market a good market
somewhere in the High Street area Thank
You chairman Thank You councillor
Bamford councillor heard and Thank You
chairman I think this particular item
speaks for itself
it is Malden high street and whilst I
have every respect for councillor
Fleming I do think that if this proposal
for these nominations failed then I
would certainly like to have councillor
nun and counselor Mays who are the ward
members for Malden north and High Street
embrace
there's and I would ask members to bear
in mind that if there was an issue for a
bridal path in Perley I'm sure councilor
white would be the first one to object
to anybody else taking on that mantle
and the same thing if there was a matter
in South Minster
I'm sure the leader would want to take
that so I do hope that members realize
that this is more than high street the
best people to look at those interests
with respect great respect to councillor
Fleming should be the to ward members
which is council and none encountered a
maze Thank You counsel flucos
nominations were and yes chairman
council fluke animated council mrs.
Furman councillor none and and
councillor herd as proposed councillor
none amazed I think Harris chairman no
that's right he said if that files
yes yeah yeah okay and so he wants me to
take that as though I'm willing to do
that that's that's fine
leader do you wish to say anything else
I mean members of the council there is
three recommendations which I'm assuming
the consensus is that that there they
would be agreed the only issue that we
might have is the vote on who the focus
group members would be so can I assume
that members are agreeing recommendation
one two and three no no not the green
recommendation little three chairman
cancer stamp
we recommend take a vote on
recommendations one and two but not
three no I did I did say that that one
two and three
three is only saying that there should
be two members appointed there would be
a vote after three for who those members
were are you suggesting that that you
wish a vote to be taken on
recommendation three apologies chairman
I misheard you the internet is
absolutely awful at the moment you're
breaking up tremendously as well
chairman I agree with the in principle
but I don't agree with the
recommendations of the two members that
been proposed by the leader Thank You
chairman just to advice accounts the
swaying and cancer Fleming had asked to
speak on this all right okay councillor
Swain first please Thank You chairman
and I do want to separate out these
recommendations and the separate vote
perhaps although I think probably mostly
they will have a general agreement but
I'm going to abstain on I want to
abstain on the recommendation to for
various reasons which I will come to
when I could speak later well because
we're debating the recommendations at
the moment do you wish me to continue
then yes please all right and apologize
to councillor Fleming this may take a
little time but I wanted to inject an
element of realism in this particular
item there were a number of smaller
scale things in there which are quite
commendable on signage waymarking
cycling facilities and so on and signage
for the turret age to act as a park and
wide but I think it is an illusion to
see the pond visitors as a great
untapped visitor base for the high
street all the lava street and the
promotion of the last street as a place
for food and drink seems to be rather
odds with the District Council's
activity and interests in providing
adequate food and drink in the comm Park
to me the problems of the high street
really are
ten problems of the highs upper high
street which is to attract new kinds of
businesses and cultural activities I'm
wary of interest groups in this pushing
forward for things like traffic
regulation one-way systems and
pedestrianisation and the emphasis on
walking and cycling the people that I
come across on the the buses getting up
to the high street I'm not going to be
walking there they're certainly not
going to be cycling you can't can't
ignore the facts of geography an
alderman and its high street the one
thing is needed is better Park and Ride
facilities generally and this seems to
have been omitted or be ignored in the
LDP process and I think we need to look
look and work for Park and rides
locations new ones perhaps that can
utilize the existing bus services so
because of these reasons on I I do know
I'm not going to vote against but I
don't support the action plan of sucks
thank you you want to come back on that
[Music]
Anna Thank You chairman and the LA high
street action plan is one of 18 projects
in the master plan that supplements
policy s5 in the LDP the master plan was
adopted in 2017 and this action plan has
taken account of changing behaviour
through the coded response people are
doing more walking and cycling
we've also considered the parking
strategy that is within the master plan
and the actions in this action plan
we'll consider that parking strategy and
how people access the town center
whether that's by bus walking by car or
by cycle and it does set out a whole
strategy for how that that can be
enabled through the master plans so the
Park and Ride you mentioned a 288 bus
the park and ride facility
new one down at the leisure center the
Parkins tried to change the dynamic of
how people arrive into the sale center
perhaps using pom probe park as a car
park and then walking up via the lower
high street and to the to the upper
middle section so if you if you just
refer to page 35 of your pack and the
paragraphs eight point two to eight
point seven they do set out that the
action plan has considered those issues
that you mentioned councillor Swain
thank you
thank you very much now councillor
Fleming Fleming thank you I just wanted
to say that I note um independent
colleagues comments about me going on to
the focus group normally I would agree
with the ward members being represented
but the point I'd like to make is that
Malden high street is used by everybody
in the district so I don't feel that
it's it's relevant here because we all
use Malden high street and visit Malden
high street so I think that we should
have representation from not just the
ward members but but somebody else I
also want to reassure members that
although I live on a farm and in a rural
location that I am actually from a town
and I also come from many generations of
shop and business people so I want to do
this because I feel that I will really
you know add early anyway
thank you thank you very much is there
any other speakers Dora and no Chairman
not unaware of right leader would you
like to sum up please and then we'll
take the votes Thank You chairman and
and I think thank you very much to
council Fleming for her input because
clearly the whole idea of the high
street is to make it like fit and proper
everybody in the district to use it is
so important
you know it's a very special high street
I thoroughly enjoy coming from South
Minister and I'm sure councilor white
enjoys coming from Pearlie to the High
Street to use the facilities and that's
why it's so important that we embrace
the homage tree as a district and that
said chairman and I think we can
probably chairman I think I'm not sure
if we have agreed recommendations one or
two but if we haven't I would propose
that we agree even subjects of the minor
amendment and I suggested and and and
then go to recommendations through each
airman yeah
I'm told council of swine wants to come
back on mrs. London's comments I will
allow this councillor swine but you have
had in your sight but please believe yes
thank you very briefly really relevant
to one of the previous comments and that
is we have to beware of that attracting
visitors from outside to the high street
isn't an inconvenience of residents of
the of modern hey bridge and so on
thank you Thank You Council fine
right then members can I assume that
that there is a consensus to agree
recommendations one two and three and
will then move to the votes on who the
membership should be chairman note my
abstention on recommendation to please
I'm sure that the mini tiger will note
that yes based on what I have is a
proposition for councillors Fleming and
none which councillor heard as indicated
that if that is lost he will he will
then propose another person but I think
it might be it might be easier to have a
vote with three names and that's Fleming
none and Mays and the last one will fall
out it is that okay with everybody
counselor hood yes cherry your when you
say the last one will fall out do you
mean in the least number of votes there
yes the least number of votes the tar is
it a problem if every member has the
opportunity to vote for two people and
by indicating the name of that person or
the name of those two people we will be
able to proceed in that manner
are you able to counsel leader chairman
I think I made a proposal earlier on
which was seconded and I think it may be
remiss of you not to put that proposal
first thank you I agree well right there
is a proposal made by the leaders the
second deed that counselor Fleming and
none be the representatives on the focus
group Tara would you take the role on
that basis please thank you chairman
members and we'll call out names
alphabetically if you could advise if
your four against abstaining please and
starting we cats the Bamford please for
Thank You counsel I Castle miss Beale
for council doesn't hate cats a bell so
can I just clarify so this is including
cancer the known and counts the Fleming
that's okay against then okay now cats
the boys of same capsule missus chana
for counselors Fleming and counselor
none thank you very much cats of Durham
or and keep cats for Edwards
chairman I've just gotten I got terrible
internet problems have just got into the
system
I have no chat facility and I can't vote
because I wasn't part of the debate for
thank you for capsule Jarvis for four
key capsule again for you can't some
race that's done abstain thank you
that's amore for key capsule Morris I
feel good so I abstain okay Absalom none
abstain
that's a Shaughnessy abstain
Sydal for cancer Skeens abstain it
cancer stamp against that's the Stokes
Epstein persuade for key cat sums
Thompson thought cats miss right
councillor miss white shemales to Lila
this Chairman she's dropping in and out
tower anyway very difficult okay
chairman the result of that vote is 16
for 3 against and 7 abstaining thank you
right that's that's motions carried and
council slimming and none will be on the
focus groups now apart from the problems
I'm having with them the internet for
the plots to do agenda item 8 minutes of
previous minutes of the council so I'll
go back to that Tara to note that since
the last meeting of the council a nap
until Wednesday the 8th of July council
agenda dispatch the northwestern area
planning committee had met on the first
of July 2020 and to receive any
questions in accordance with the council
and committee procedure rule 62 is there
any questions okay that concludes agenda
item 8 and then we can now proceed to
agenda item 11 rebel development plan
document housing and leader would you
please presenting Thank You chairman
Tamara I think a good way to miss the
league I think he's going to take us
through ground of this report and then
if you can come to me with the
recommendations of the grateful thank
you mr. Lee muted so I members I've
moved the speaker part away from my
mouth and Thank You chairman members of
so you've got the report in front of
them and they'll be aware that
previously in February of this year the
counts was agreed to start prepare a
development plan document in relation to
various impacts from the potential new
nuclear power station at Brad well as
members were fully aware the new nuclear
power station will not
be determined by us as the counsel any
say in sip and is determined by the
Secretary of State and we will be
consulted in that process it's likely
that new nuclear power station is going
to have impacts in relation to housing
employment and other matters and that is
what the point of the development plan
document is is to protect us in the
future against adversarial developments
and to give us some form of control over
where these forms of development will be
sited located and how we can ensure to
mitigate harm and impacts at the moment
a placate or the document is very much
in its infancy and if a number of
reports have been commissioned that have
been necessary to be able to bring
forward this document and to get it
adopted through the formal process
because the decisions we make will need
to be evidence based and these
supporting documents will provide that
evidence to be able to allow us to come
to reasonable and informed judgments
that are robust and defendable however
as part of the process officers have
already considered that really to look
to gain maximum benefits and to ensure
that it's a sustainable development that
we should look to try to encourage the
housing allocation within the district
rather than potentially outside because
also that would make it a more difficult
way to manage and mitigate so that's
already been something that has gone
through an obviously we would like
members endorsement of that which is
point one however the second point I
think is the more important one is that
officers would be very keen to get
members input at an early stage into the
ideas and direction of travel in
relation to housing as I've already said
and as the report explains in numerous
times the final decision on matters such
as this will need to be heavily
influenced by the evidence basis and by
the facts that come out of these reports
but there may be some ideas that we wish
to not look at if possible or some that
may be more favorable and that all can
go into the melting pot for us as the
authority to come up with the decision
so for that reason office is requesting
an agreement for a members workshop
to allow officers to explain some more
context Oxley this report has and also
to get some important direction from
members and that is the recommendation -
Thank You chairman thank you very much
leader I've got several speakers do you
wish to say anything before I come back
to you well yeah except that chairman to
get the debate going I think children I
think members need to be mindful of the
fact that regardless of refusing the
planning application to deal with the
Geological Survey the the DCO process is
still continuing in the background at
speed and we really need to set
ourselves up chairman so that if this
project does go ahead in the future and
mr. Lee's absolutely quite right that we
will not be deciding whether it does or
not but what we need to do is protect
the districts and I think to enable us
to do that we under understand what
officers want for members and this is
the opportunity to do it so generally as
far as the recommendations that are
concerned I would propose that we agree
recommendation one but with regards to
recommendation to chairman I would
propose a different recommendation which
hopefully miss Byrd has now gotten if
she checks her email address and my
recommendation is as follows chairman
that workshops because this
recommendation actually at the moment
just provides for one workshop and I'm
sure I'm sure that members want more
than one workshop so that workshops have
provided for members at the earliest
opportunity chairmen which will include
the opportunity to provide comment on
the principles of delivering housing to
meet the need of red wallpaper and Power
Station once operational and that in
advance of any such workshop members are
provided with background papers in a
timely manner now chairman that final
sentence that I read again and the in
advance of any such workshops members
are provided with background papers in a
timely manner the reason why I'm
proposing that we have that chairman
because
we seemed to be with virtual meetings we
seemed to be called in to meetings and
we get information up on the screens
members find it difficult depending what
apparatus they're using to be able to
see the documents to digest them which
would allow them to comment properly so
I think chairman last I've proposed that
we have that in this particular
recommendation it might be something
that officers take into consideration
when they set these workgroups up and I
know that several of us were in a preamp
yesterday and again it would have been
useful if we'd had a lot of those papers
in advance but chairman that's that's my
two proposals and and I hope given the
circumstances members will support them
because we need to get on with this
because the alternative chairman is if
we don't start this process of and the
DCO accelerates there's a lot of people
were thinking it will do we could then
find ourselves open to speculative
developments throughout the district
chairman and that really would fly in
the in the face of the principles of our
local development plan thank you that
second the revised recommendation great
council a Banford first counselor swine
infant
Thank You chairman I mean social support
what the leader has said I did sort of
say our second but I just wanted to
emphasize something in the report on
page 51 which is a very welcomed
approach and that is to do with the fact
that the offices will use their well I
think they use the word encourage that
any permanent housing will not be
delivered through the development
consent water and I think that's quite
important that we sort of press that
part of it so that's the point I wanted
to make chairman thank you and
councillor Logan there we go thank you
chairman Thank You members and looking
back for the minutes
in February where was an agreement to go
I hate this work my concern is that this
long a little bit premature obviously
we're talking as if this this power
station will happen and with the
political situations from Chinese
government and the UK government and the
degree of a failing relationship we
can't be sure of that
with the also what concerns me is when
when we looked at this through a very
long meeting in on page 314 then we
looked at some costings that were in
potentially doing this book and those
that costing tens of three hundred and
fifty five thousand pounds so I'm
concerned at the moment that we may be
spending money I'm doing preliminary
works on something that that may or may
not happen so I think that we should
look at suspending or postponing at
least this this work because I keep on
hearing how busy we get the bodies and
this is going to take it off a lot of
time and money which is a real concern
for me there's also something in the
report it talks about in six and 3.2 3.3
sorry three point two point three
we need more points and this is it can
help to secure an improved legacy for
the district two things and me just
account in that statement and members
know my my feelings on this so I'm not
going to wait right now bang on for
hours about it but it says it came but
Ken does not mean it will and I'm still
stuck in a place where yeah we go and do
all of this amount of work for something
that causes massive amounts of
destruction and negativity across the
district and even the previous an
application chair wasn't wasn't approved
and buoyed by unanimous vote by the
things in Section three point three
point five the report which is a good
report and says it gives a detailed for
us to scrutinize and that's our rock it
mentioned it which is something that
really interested me it said that the
income is extremely love
in the district which is quite a
challenge because I'm three point three
point six then talks about 71% of
housing being three or more bedrooms so
then it gives me a degree of concern is
that would would be consider that that
puttin housing down at Brad well to
support a monstrously a horrific nuclear
power station development in my view
would ruin the district would they be
cheaper level housing which really puts
people into it a bit of a housing trap
really it also talks in three point six
point one about penalties so I found the
tone of some of the report to be a
little bit scare mongering because it's
all we can have we can get penalized if
we don't deliver that the right housing
in the right way we put in under three
point six point two our LDP going to
deliver four thousand six hundred and
fifty dwellings
well let's deliver them and let's see
what the decision is based on what the
government safe is as the leader and as
matt said it's really not our decision
and I agree we need to do some pragmatic
works but I think we'd be going a little
bit too quickly down a road that really
he's going to my humblest of use
disaster for us as a district and also
in my conclusion that chair in in
Section four point one there's it says
it says in the conclusion it says in six
point three of that conclusion
it says implications risk none I'm not
sure that I actually agree with there is
no risk implications for a fiscal or a
security or a health and safety or a
financial or a growth measure for the
whole of the district so then my
concerns and I can't support the
recommendations and I'm experimentation
to to know the report and to revisit the
work when needed when a bit more
clarity's is gained through the
situation to do with the government
Thank You councillor none here thank you
very much chairman councilor laggin
stolen my thunder
chairman I agree with him that this is
premature I have no problem at all with
workshops but don't think we should
proceed beyond workshops at this stage
Thank You counselor swine and Thank You
chairman with regard to this question
about whether we can refer any action or
not I would like some clarification as
to how the work on this document fits
within the timetable of both the LDP and
the anticipated schedule for the power
station consent only that how that fits
in it depends on whether this can be
said or not but I have a more
fundamental which we say dispute with
this and that is that it says in both
two places that the housing needs should
be met within the district I think this
is quite wrong and I think it's far more
relevant to consider South Minster than
great Braxtons and in the area that is
affected or would be providing houses
should be much wider I agree this is
going to make things a lot more
complicated for the planners but it is
quite unreasonable to expect all that
anticipate housing to be in the district
councillor Thompson thank you Jim Thank
You members I believe I'm sure one of
the officers can confirm that I think
this work is being in any case partially
funded by BRB but my point then the
leader and councillor bamp that have
already made it but I can't emphasize
enough if we don't have this ready when
we need it we will have no control over
any of it we can't control whether we
have a power station or not but if we do
and I must
I'm becoming less keen on it with every
passing day but I want to be realistic
about what we can control and what we
can't and if we're going to need new
housing or park-and-ride or whatever we
need to be able to control what we have
and where we have it and that would help
cover some a counselor counselors know
counsellor logins concerned about the
size of houses type affordability etc we
can't leave it for the DCO process that
happens at central government level and
will be influenced almost entirely by
BRB if that happens thank you thank you
thank you Karen um yeah no cancel like
I'm just reminded me that I have read
something in the report that I
considered to be inaccurate 3.3.5 page
51
it says firstly income levels for those
residents currently working in the
district are considered extremely low
that's not my understanding everything
I've read is that mean income levels are
compared to the rest of the country hi I
just wanted to comment on that thank you
[Music]
referring to three point seven point two
on page 53 we just confirmed that this
development is not part of the LDP and
I'm wondering why we've got reference to
the five-year housing land supply if we
if we didn't have this it shouldn't make
any difference should it because this
would be a windfall mr. Stilley there's
a question for you immediately there mr.
Lee yep so chanter I get the technology
to work to be honest it's it's a little
difficult just to answer that question
in isolation it does feed into a number
of the various points that
been raised so I don't if you want to
carry on and then come back to me I'll
talk it in the hole or maybe pick up now
okay thank you now the final speaker
I've I've got is councillor down
that's the Dharam thank you yeah Thank
You chairman chairman I think the whole
point about this is is notwithstanding
the the vote the other day the sort of
exercise takes a very long time to get
any sort of conclusion to it and we need
to start it straight away although of
course we know there's a chance albeit a
small my opinion of the power station
when kappa'd we got to be able to to be
able to dictate that we have the right
homes the right time and in the right
place and that work has to start
otherwise if we end up having to do it
when our backs against the wall we won't
have chanced chance to to deliberate
properly so I will support this this
recommendation we need to get cracking
we need to do it now thank you thank you
chairman I I think I can see where the
consensus is going and it is absolutely
important that we we get on with this
and there was a question about resources
and I think that's dealt with resources
financial which is dealt with an
implication chairman paragraph six four
where it says the only potential cost
will be defending planning application
and planning appeals if we don't get on
with this because we just know where
developers are going to go next and as I
said earlier to him and the DCO process
is still continuing at speed in the
background and and and councillor
Bamford is absolutely right if we don't
do something and we don't get on with it
and what could actually happen is that
the DCO could determine where we have
these houses
and you know I mean I mean I'm grateful
for councillor Swain's comments about
South moons but there is likely to go in
Mauldin east as they are in Burnham or
anywhere else so we need to have some
control over this and you know Lee
you've dropped out so I think I'm back
in now well pause you there because I
think mr. Lee wants to come back to
cover a few points before you do your
final something that I yeah chairman
I'll give way to mr. Lee and I just hope
that it wasn't him who muted me because
I'm gonna check any member how much I
wanted to thank you chairman I'd start
off members Bobbsey quoting some much
more intelligent than myself about
hoping for the best and preparing for
the worst and to say listen I think the
point of this DPD is exactly that I
develop plan document as I explained you
know needs evidence that which has
already been started to be commissioned
so and we've signed agreements with that
so actually supposing it would not
really make any savers in that respect
but that's a bit of a moot point the
point is that the generation of a
document such as this takes 18 months to
two years there is a need for us to
start to prepare for this if in the DCO
is granted if we wait until that stage
we will not be able to protect the
district we will have an extended period
where adversarial planning applications
will be coming in where applicants wish
to put them we will not be able to
really have much of a defense then
because there will be an acknowledged
need for housing and I think that ties
into councilor herds query about why is
the LDP referenced because the LDP takes
into account the predicted housing
demand for the next 15 years it does not
take into account the predicted housing
demands and Bradwell nuclear power
station and if they what when the deso
is granted if it is granted that will be
a material consideration in every plan
application that Wilmont money
he changed the expected housing demands
for the district
so therefore the four and a half
thousand that we've got granted and
being built out will not be enough and
therefore there will be in a demand and
every applicant every developer is going
to be able to argue that and show that
we are failing to Meowth five-year land
supply if the council can't demonstrate
a five-year loans by all our policies in
relation to housing location fall away
and it all becomes back to sustainable
development and I'm sure most of the
members that particularly in
southeastern North West that we're here
four or five years ago and a little bit
longer remember how difficult that is
remember how challenging that is we
really have had over that time some
applications for pretty large-scale
developments that as office as the
members we really tried to resist forced
upon us by pins and if we don't do the
preparation work that we need to do to
protect ourselves from adversarial
occations we will end up in a situation
worse than we were and that is my honest
professional judgment this isn't saying
we support the idea of a new comparison
this isn't even saying it we all won't
come what this is just is us getting
ready to actually be able to deal with
the situation as and when it progresses
but as I said these documents take 18
months to years to progress if we don't
start now we will not be ready at the
time of the DCO process thank chairman
the only other point when says the wards
emulation to do their wages points
that's actually just taken from our slaw
which is stating that the salaries for
people within the district are quite low
compared to I think it's Essex but
that's actually from one of our adopted
documents but I think that was really
covering all the points Thank You
chairman Thank You mr. lay back to you
your completion of your summing up okay
Janice so I think we dealt with
resources we we dealt with the DCO who
could in you know who could actually
determine where these houses go we don't
something should the project ahead and I
was just going to respond to something
counselor the nun said about you know
beyond workshops the whole idea of this
this is chairman Issa's or members is to
is to hold these workshops get members
views come back to Council and get some
kind of an endorsement from Council as
to what we want to do now anybody that
was on the council during the local
development plan process will know how
complicated that is to do it you know
we're talking a probably an 18-month or
two-year process there were public
consultations regarding this DVD it's
gonna take time and if we don't get
going now just with this little bit of
you know what we're trying to do now is
just have a couple of workshops with all
members so that we can understand
everybody's ideas about this so that we
can take it to the next stage everything
will be reported back through Council
we're not endorsing a new power station
what we're actually doing is protecting
ourselves chairman now chairman I've
I've I've made a proposal that we agree
recommendation number one but I made a
more inclusive recommendation with
regards to number two she was able to
put that up on the screen yeah well I've
sent it to her by email so you know I'm
beginning to get the hang of this now oh
there we go look you've amended the one
that I meant it's so Germany
it says the workshops be provided for
all members at the earliest of which
will include the opportunity to provide
comments on the principles principles of
delivering housing to meet the need of
bread want power station once
operational and that in advance of any
such workshops members are provided with
background papers in a timely manner now
to me chairman we've got two very
sensible recommendations there and
they've been proposed and seconded and
I'd ask that you put the question now
thank you thank you very much leader
members can see that are you willing to
accept these two recommendations or do
you wish me to carry out a vote chairman
chairman also slang is there now to
conflict between the first and the
second the first one says housing to get
within the district but the second one
opens the possibility of discussing a
wider area of housing upon where people
come I don't I don't think I don't think
that I thought the intention was all
within the district we can only we only
have any control over within our
district councillor Swain Tara will you
take the roll please
please chair yes
so I on recommendation one do we put
those up on the screen again Jim I think
you can yes please
yes please
on the screen please Tara there we go
recommendation one and members if you
could um just advice for against abstain
please starting me counselor Bamford
four-passenger sorry's not present Kat
stabile poor cats the bill against voice
Stein this channel for cancer Darin for
cancer Edwards against cancer Fleming
for cats Africa or Thank You councillor
Hawker or cancer hurt against so him for
he counts a whole ball that's a Jarvis
boo cats the keys for
- Megan again spacer thank you
cancer maze counts amazed for cancer
Morris again against Newcastle Siddle
for cancer scans against and sadly for
Thank You cancer stilts for access way
Thank You council mr. Thompson oh you
cancer white a chairman fee result of
that vote in relation to recommendation
1 he's 17 for 9 against and 1 abstention
carried keep roll recommendation yes of
course again as the full number starts
recaps of Bamford please for Thank You
counselor miss Beale for that's labelled
abstain Thank You cancerboys up Stein
thank you mrs. chana
poor thank you
cats the Durham before he cancer Edwards
beginning thankee sir mrs. Fleming full
for Thank You cancer Harker for ahead
for
for Enki cancer help for you can't so
Jarvis for you can't Serkis for Lacan
against raise for mourning a growing
hanky cancer none for dick cancer
Shaughnessy or as the Siddal for that's
the schemes for for in cats was right
wasn't that awesome
so chairman the result of the vote for
recommendation to as amended was 22 for
3 against and 2 abstentions carried item
12 appointment to vacant seats on
committees and contained on page 61 262
leader Thank You chairman chairman I
think it will probably be easier to do
this in to mendacious so chairman with
regards to recommendation one I would
propose chairman that councillor Darwin
is appointed to the strategy and
resources committee counsel of Bamford
is appointed to the licensing committee
counselor Fleming is appointed to the
investigating and disciplinary committee
councillors Siddal is appointed to the
investigating and disciplinary panel
councillor Jarvis is appointed to the
corporate governance working group are
so moved
yes thank you I think the herd wants to
speak on the nominations but but I think
it really should be just a matter for
reporting councillor hood Thank You
chairman I understand I understand
some of those nominations however I
would like to make the point again I
have the greatest respect for councillor
Jarvis that the corporate governance
working party has but one independent
member and that is myself and I would
like to propose that counselor counselor
stamp councillor Wendy stamp goes on to
this corporate work governance working
party in order to give representation
not only to burn them but also a bit
more of a balance on the council
seconded right
do does the council agree the first is
it five bullet points well the first
fire bullet points as I said should just
be fun outing everybody happy for those
two so we need to have a vote on the
fifth bullet point that's a corporate
governance working party there's two
nominations I think counts two Jarvis
and councillor Stamp and I've got
councillor
Jarvis wishing to speak now councillor
Jarvis Thank You chair members I've got
the greatest respect accounts for stamp
this particular committee though I am
and keen so this working but I am keen
to be involved with it I do have quite a
lot of experience in governance and got
his childhood qualification in
governance and I think on behalf of the
whole council I'm very keen to have
influence through that working group
because I think there are some
governance issues that do need attention
so
greatest respect for counselor stamp but
in terms of representing and making
change happen I've very keen to be
involved in this working group Thank You
children was councillor Jarvis and so
Tara if you'll call the roll on that and
what will happen members gets a majority
vote he will be the representative if he
fails to get the majority vote we will
then take a vote thought counselor stamp
is that understood Tara ok council sent
please please do so perfectly entitled
to do so I was one of the nominees and I
also have the greatest respect for
councillor Jarvis um but really to try
and get some balance back on these
groups Chairman I think don't think it
should all be replaced by conservative
counselors um cast Luka has been very
vocal recently about sharing these
services and well this is a prime
opportunity to actually share some of
these reserved roles to actually
independent or non-aligned councillors
so I I really welcome the opportunity
and thank you for being nominated I
doubted rest under captain Ellis Jones
chairman but I do also think that I
could contribute greatly on this
corporate governance working partner but
I appreciate you cancel the job is too
so thank you tarah call the roll please
for those in favor of councillor Jarvis
so again it's straightforward for
against abstain Thank You chairman Casa
Bamford for thank you tax bill for and
just to advise on now leaving the
meeting cancelable against but with the
greatest respect
cancerboys lunchtime this is channel or
cancer durham or thank you casa Edwards
against cancer mrs. Fleming for cancer
Freaker for the Hulk again with respect
to councillor Jarvis but against thank
you
cancer home for o-katsu Jarvis we're all
of stags I don't wish to get in on we're
in vain thank you thank you
cancer keys for thank you cancel nagging
for is against with respect for Maurice
counselor job excellent an interest of
balance against thank you very much
councillor none abstain assure to see
against you cats a fiddle it's a great
shame that council is done it's got such
good qualities can't be a member of this
group however I have to vote for thank
you
that's the skenes I still can't see why
she can't be a another member but
against thank you cat sister and I'm
gonna do the same is and councillor
Jarvis I'm going to abstain or not vote
for myself councillor Jarvis thank you
cats the stoats abstain cats a swing
against like council mrs. Thompson for
thank you and cat so miss white she's
present
mr. chairman the results of that vote
are 14 for 8 against and five
abstentions thank you very much
14 for 8 against I think that is about
garv this is elected and thank you
everybody that concludes there's the
small tool to deal with isn't here yeah
Thank You chairman I think you called
but you're you're breaking up I don't
know if it's this end or not
Gemini's I think the first part of this
is state is quite straightforward so
chairman our I would propose that that
council agrees recommendation to I think
that recommendation 3 is a little bit
more complicated and and unless the
monitoring office has got something to
say on it I think I oppose chairman that
that the non-aligned members consult
with the monitoring off so with regards
to appointment of substitutes because
I'm I'm not quite sure how that works I
read the government's around this today
and it's not a hundred percent clear but
I think this is one I could see your
problem
leader and I tend to agree there are
three people who are not a group
therefore it seems to answer itself I
think I think mr. Krause needs to be
consulted on they're not going with you
and and you know this is why I had great
concerns about this you know I'm great
support of what we're trying to achieve
here but it right from the beginning
it's the governance that concerns me
going forward so chairman ah I'll
certainly propose it's at your dog
barking German I propose one of many I
propose that we agree recommendation to
but I think and you might want to put
that to counsel but recommendation story
I think we need a little bit more on
there with
gasps vomiting officer thank you I've
got to speak Chancellor Stanton
councillor Morris council stamp Thank
You chairman I think it's very difficult
to put motion to before in separate two
little three and if you actually read
what the emotion and the agreement was a
political group is defined by having
three or more members I think you'll
find two independent non-aligned is two
and one non-aligned is one and they're
separate they're not in a group and
while Katsav Luka was like I said
earlier very vocal about trying to be
inclusive for everything it's a shame he
didn't actually carry that through on
record two little one about trying to
include other members then the
Conservatives on those groups but we are
where we are as class with Lukas there's
nine loads and loads of times
I don't think and it said it's not
supposed to be politically imbalanced
this is an imbalance and to qualify to
be on this group then you've got eight
members it should be four four if in
September when the statutory annual
takes place chairman and the group to do
change and you've got three or more in
to be constituted as a recognized
political group then fine this group can
also be then new members can be proposed
and put on there but it stands at the
moment chairman it's got to be for
independence and for conservatives
otherwise it makes a mockery of the
debate we had on the 23rd of June and
counts with lucre you can you can most
probably say this is why you is
concerned editor we did put the option
forward for the offices to actually help
and get involved to make sure this was
watertight and the essence is correct we
are supposed to been trying to be more
inclusive with everybody to get a equal
stay on this council but yet again you
have proved on too little one that you
actually don't practice what you preach
Thank You chairman I've got mr. wishes
to come in
mr. Kuo and I might disagree with you
just house yes thank thank you for
telling me in advance
and you may disagree that's that's very
good um yes uh on this little - we're
bound by the the agreed minutes of the
23rd of June council and and that and
and that says if a motion three that
eight members should reflect the balance
of the membership of the council now I
know that it motion two had already said
that political balance provisions should
be waived in other words the actual
strict adherence as the regulation set
things out but then motion three makes
it clear that the eight members should
reflect the balance of the membership of
the council however no group should have
a majority on the committee the emotion
then goes on to define group as three or
more members so I mean I take it trying
to interpret the motions and and I admit
they weren't as straightforward as we
would have liked them to have been that
relates to no group can have a majority
on the committee so that's just defining
group for those purposes the the
principle part of motion three as I read
it is that the eight members should
reflect the balance of the membership of
the council now that means you've got to
take account of the composition of the
whole council so we have two groups with
the Conservatives have are I understand
fifty-one percent of the membership the
independents have thirty nine percent
and then there are the non-aligned
members who are not a group not a group
for political balance purposes nor
within the confines of these motions but
they are still membership of the council
and so following the actual wording of
motion three I don't think unless the
council is going to change its motion
entirely that that it has to be 4-3 or
one now in relation to little three
chairman if I may just take the chance
of dealing with that one as well
kurz political balance provisions have
been waived I think there is a Liberty
there there is a freedom for someone
other than a non-aligned member to be
named as substitute but obviously not a
conservative because then that would go
against the principle of the committee
having no group having a majority so it
would have to be a non-aligned member or
an independent Thank You mr. Kraus some
of it I agree some I don't but I shall
keep that to myself for now and let the
council decide
I've got six speakers starting counselor
stamp Morris I would just like to point
out that one of the counselors that is
listed in little toe it's got a very
good chance of being found to have
brought the council into district group
should we not be waiting to see what
happens with the report that is two
weeks overdue I hasten to add with
everything that's gone on are we not
being a little bit premature in that
trying to pull this all together here I
know I don't think I need to answer that
at the moment Council the swine no you
wouldn't would you Bob
and also the swine yeah Thank You
chairman um it's the position of these
non-aligned and I and the this phase
that scripting here about a recognized
political entity they are not a
political entity and I don't think if we
knew Lou consider the three people
involved they would want to be
considered as a political entity so I
think they fall outside the the
arrangements for political we're not
political balance but avoiding a
majority for anyone
there are only two entities in this and
that is the conservative groups and the
independent groups and to have an alarm
non-aligned person chosen by the counts
on or for the council to designate an
alternative one raise a bit farcical so
I think I'm I think one has to exclude
these the three from the the balanced
composition of the JSC Thank You Council
the Lagon thank you thank you chair I've
got this thing going through my head
though I deliberated whether I should
speak in this way or not but we just
gotta build a bridge and get over
ourselves you know release the waffle
and Tosh and politics that's going on
this council is absolutely disgraceful I
have no problem not being on this
committee being honest you know as an
elected member like everybody who sits
in the chamber when we can we're there
to represent the people when we're
playing games in politics so let's not
do that let's knock that Simon crouchers
spoke well and he said about the makeup
of the council rather the political
group I would be very grateful to serve
on the committee until September if
council decides I won't lose any sleep
if I don't but you will need to start to
have a bloomin good look in the mirror
and start to vote for what you think is
light rather than the political first
council yet just the technology chairman
Thank You chairman I broke the motion
and the motion stipulates and is what
councillor stampers just said that the
the group is a group of three people
that has a leader and that meets as a
group the three non-aligned members are
not a group so therefore and I
appreciate cancers like Baggins
unanimously by saying what he just said
and I think he would be
asset to this particular committee if he
was part of it
however the the way the council is
constituted currently is to political
groups so therefore it should be at the
moment for conservatives and for
independents who are part of the
independent group here is quite simple
we are playing semantics here and this
to me is just trying to create barriers
for this committee to move forward and
do its job and that's what we should be
focusing on not this strange trying to
create barriers and problems we need to
ensure that this committee is formed and
gets on with its job Thompson Thank You
chairman I seem to recall cancellous
oodles vote was motion specifically did
not exclude non-aligned members I mean
I've got the slightest problem with
councillor Lacan being a member is he
bearing in mind that I'm one of the ones
on the list and therefore I'd be sitting
with me and I'd be sitting with him if
this goes ahead and I'm sorry I said it
at the time it was a badly written
motion with apologies to count some
civil announcements about councillors
Fluker actually came up with one that
would work because it had the potential
for a slightly variable it was either
seven or eight number of people sitting
on it so that in fact the situation
couldn't arise where I the group has a
majority the point is if that councillor
laggin isn't available then we're back
to everything we were trying to avoid in
the first place which is one group
having the majority over the other it's
I think the whole thing should
unfortunately that the group the
committee probably needs to sit but
actually it should all go back to be
looked at again and come up with
something
actually thank you Jarvis hey German I
just wanted to say that I certainly
understood that the balance read the
motions and I understood the balance was
going to be four and four and when with
the greatest respect account sir a lag
on who I think would be an asset to the
group I was surprised at the way it was
interpreted by mr. Kuo I didn't call him
ins we spoke about this and I do
understand that there's a difficulty
there is some difficulty in the wording
of the motion but I think on balance
quite clearly the motion was counseled
with stamps and and councillor settles
and I think you know if the majority of
people clearly have an understanding
that it would be four and four and that
is the most practical way to operate it
I would move that that's how in fact
councillors interpreted thanks Janet
thank you I've got I've got mrs. Stamp
who wants to come back councillor I'll
bring this to a conclusion council stamp
Thank You chairman for allowing me to
come back can I just remind the members
and thank you for councillor Thompson
and everybody else who's now deciding to
say whatever they wish to say which is
their democratic right the reason behind
this motion was because of the way the
Standards Committee was was possibly
going to be taken forward that was
reflected more and a better light can we
focus back on that they own the whole
idea of this motion whether it wasn't
super blue written
I mean don't forget some of us are still
fairly new counselors but we did
actually ask for advice and we were
welcoming on it yes oh please don't
criticize the motion if you could write
it better then I suggest you do write it
better members whoever feels it it's not
a good enough motion the idea behind it
chairman is that we can actually have a
fair and balanced Council to look at any
in discrepancies misdemeanors issues and
it's dealt with fairly not with the
political hammer thank you for allowing
me to speak
yes word and Thank You chairman actually
I echo what councilor and stamp has said
because this motion was written in the
spirit of neutrality and balance and in
order to protect the reputation of this
council to have a four and four
committee of those recognized groups
whether they be political or not but the
Thorat but the two recognized groups and
that's why I would agree that it should
be four and four Thank You counsel I
mean Fleming Thank You chairman um can
we just rewind to mr. Crouch's comments
I understood it that he said that the
non-aligned could sit on the committee
but could only sub with an independent
ah make up I know anyway sorry to
interrupt you carry on so good mr.
Krause just confirm what he was saying
about that justice would you like to
come back and explain yeah this is a
very difficult motion it really is and
and and just to clarify chairman I'm not
playing semantics as was suggested I'm
trying to make sense of what I think is
a very difficult
motion passed by counsel so what I meant
was that the non the substitute for for
the non-aligned member because members
took away the political balance
provisions I think there probably is a
leeway for that not to be a non-aligned
person but it M namely it can't be a
conservative because of this because of
the wording of the motion but I think it
could be an independence all I'm so I'm
not saying it should be I'm saying I
think there's freedom for it to be so if
members want
Thank You mr. quest I've got the
consensus of the council that I believed
that they think it should be four and
four I have to say and I told mrs. stamp
when she approached me before the
meeting that I thought that it was a bad
governance at what she was proposing but
the intentions were quite clear to me
that it should be foreign before now
having said that are you happy Council
to make that I make the ruling there is
forum for you wish to take this to a
vote the fourth line to add to that list
I'll do that with pleasure
it will be canceled at Wendy stem thank
you and and so in that case that does
away with the necessity to deal with
little item three so leader coming back
to you sorry to impose my will on you on
this but the foot the names will be as
you've laid out with the addition of
mrs. Stamp
are you happy with that leader yeah I'm
more than happy with that and I'd also
like to thank councilor laggin for
volunteering to be done on the line and
and also to his substitute as well but I
mean we have a complete different
interpretation now from the monitoring
officer so I can only apologize to
members for the way this report was
brought forward because I think if we've
done this before the report came forward
then it would have saved an awful lot of
time but I'm more than content with this
it's all to do with openness
transparency and fairness and I grew
this committee lights made Council
Marcus is asked to speak the decision
my mind has been taken and the counters
agree but councillor Morris things have
you'll say I'm just a little concerned
that one of the counselors that is named
in this has been or will be found today
by should be emitted
they should be emitted if I brought the
count in the Morris three ninety eight I
think the council just going back to the
previous item they need to just vote on
the membership of the joint Standards
Committee we take out the non-aligned
member and add in CAD system recorded
vote seconded yes chairman if you can
just indicate for against stain please
can you can you explain exactly what
we're voting on again and with the names
involved yeah they're with me I keep it
on the screen
so it's this recommendation
recommendation to the membership what
mr. made the joint standards committee
in accordance with the nomination as the
two political groups taking out a bit
about the non-aligned member based on
the following nominations so for
conservatives which is counts the helm
counts versus China counselor mr.
Thompson counselor Jarvis for
independent Scouts the non cats the maze
cats the Basinger cancer stump and then
the parish councilors John Anderson and
town cancer
Peter stilts and an independent person
from a pool of three okay okay start
recounts the Banford please or thank you
that's the Basinger Casa Beall counts
the bell for the boys capsule mrs. chana
for I did was just big curly but never
mind
Casa Doran or Edwards or Thank You
council Fleming for that's a Fluker for
you cats the Harker I was dying at four
cats a home for cancer home keys for
cancer knockin the joy of being not
aligned as you can vote whichever way
you want so for keep
cancer race for for cats amorous we've
canceled around the Sonoma
should be allowed nearest and so I would
have to vote against if Anderson weren't
on it I would be voting for Thank You
customers
councilman thought you can't so
Shaughnessy Oh for cancer schemes with
reservations for cancer stop sorry
Terra's writing for thank you
cats the stoats for kick out the suede
oh you cancel mrs. Thompson and cancel
this right if she's still with us thank
you
yeah chairman the results of that vote
are 23 for one against and 2 abstentions
thank you very much thank you that's
carried therefore and now we could go on
to agenda item 13 medium-term financial
strategy on pages 63 to 98 leader yeah
Thank You chairman and before I hand
over to the director resources and one
five one officer mr. Leslie can I on
behalf of all members chairman pay
tribute to them to what the finance and
resources department have done over the
last five months they've done enormous
amount of work that's gone into
producing this report and being in mind
they're also doing a business unusual
and the additional work which they've
had to take because of the health
emergency and just to prove what they've
actually achieved this department
chairman we are the first council in
Essex to close down our accounts for the
year 1920 so I'm pleased to say that
that's moving on as well so a very very
in-depth we pull and chairman through
you I'm going to hand over now to
crystal Leslie just to go through the
headlines I'm afraid that they're not
good but through you chairman I'll defer
to mr. Leslie Thank You mr. Leslie all
right Thank You chairman Thank You
leader
just to talk through the report for you
an estimate of the in year financial
impact of Kovac 19 was presented to
council in May but it was a group that a
revised medium-term financial strategy
would be prepared to show the indicative
medium-term effect and impact on the
general fund since May members have been
made aware of additional kovat 19 in E
earth pressures including confidential
ones where there are confidential forums
to discuss those I would draw members
attention to Table one of the report
which is at paragraph 4.1 and that table
totals those Kovac 19 pressures and adds
other variances identified as part of
the medium-term financial strategy
review this shows the total additional
pressures in each year of the MTFs there
is an expectation that some of these
pressures are a worst-case scenario but
others such as car parking income are
dependent on future activity and can't
be accurately predicted so it could be
better or could be worse this of course
isn't a unique situation to mulden
additionally on the 2nd of July our
government announced further funding to
support income losses and it has
mentioned at paragraph four point eight
of the report details are still do be
released so it's currently unclear how
much Molden will receive and as such no
estimate has been included in these
figures so potential for these figures
to to improve as a result of that also
like to move on to table 2 of the report
which is at paragraph 4.4 and this adds
those pressures from table 1 to
february's medium-term financial
strategy which was approved by council
to produce a revised general fund
balance it's worth noting that without
the savings achieved a transformation
program the position that would be worse
now minimum general fund level is set at
2.6 million
kovat 19 as an example of why there is a
level and the reduction of the balance
below
2.6 million in response to Kovac 19
would be justified however a plan to
replace the general fund banks would
need to be put in place should it fall
below that minimum level to highlight
for you that at the bottom of Table two
there is a row entitled balance without
additional drawdown and this shows the
position without those new Kovach 19
pressures and how a general fund would
be sustainably maintained above 2.6
million in the medium-term should we not
have that to that impact of kovat 19
there are of course project these are of
course projections on a do-nothing basis
with no additional savings or income
assumed and relying completely on the
general fund balance to fund the costs
indeed section 5 of the report sets out
some high-level next steps in terms of
future actions to address this also the
out turn report is being drafted and
will be presented to Council on the 6th
of August and will report in fact a
better general composition than the 4.8
million projected additionally earmark
reserves are also higher and will be
reviewed for the potential to support
the cost pressures and invest in the
recovery so in summary of Kovach 19
can't be accurately projected at this
stage however we know it will be
significant and it will be constantly
monitored and reported it is important
at this time that plans begin to be good
in place to commence this financial
recovery and these come forward to
members for approval Thank You chair
Thank You leader before I come back to
you do you want to say anything before I
go to members well chairman Lee the
recommendation is is straightforward and
I would propose at this stage that we
agree a chairman and then obviously mr.
Leslie's bringing forward a lot more
information for Council on the 6th of
August and obviously we look forward to
that
but at the the recommendation really is
to is to note the
dicks thank you need a second thank you
the swine read counselor swine so yes I
grieved that FNT what can I give you my
comments then questions the paragraph
four point aid and where it mentions
about where losses more than five said
counsel and planned income that does
that mean that we may be in line for
more of a government support which so
far is six hundred and seventy two
thousand I wonder if it's possible to
give a broad breakdown for next time as
to how much of that is attributable to
conveyed related activities and how much
could be considered as compensating us
for lost revenue I know that the
corporate projects working group met
last week will we get the outcome of
that working group shortly or at least
next time we are discussing anything
financial and a compliment mr. Leslie on
the financial work that he's done but I
think even so we can't um shouldn't
underestimate the dick the seriousness
of the financial situation and and I
think sooner or later we may have to
look closely and what we are doing that
we're not legally obliged to do and to
see if that is a source of any
additional savings this may be something
for strategy resources to look at but I
think members might appreciate knowing
or having some idea what resources are
going on these areas that we don't not
legally obliged to do thank you
questions briefly please absolutely and
thank you once again councillor swing
and indeed the pressures are significant
and so
supporting highlighting that with
regards additional funding so you've got
the new details coming forward or
hopefully they will be out soon as I
think the announcement has made a couple
of couple weeks ago now so once you've
got those details we'll be able to
report back to members on that it should
be noted that indeed six hundred and
seventy two thousand pounds from the
last tranche of grants and that was part
of a 3.2 billion pound funding injection
by government
this funding injection is half a billion
pounds so it remains to be seen what we
get out of that but obviously we will
report that back to members of course we
will look at as you quite rightly say
statutory non statutory obligations that
the council has something that sir it's
a crucial part to understand it have the
council operates and its services
absolutely taken on board and again that
with the working group side of it I
believe there is a reporting mechanism
for the working groups and of course
whatever comes to handle those will be
able to feed into the medium term
financial strategies I think mr. Liu's
answered your questions councillor Logan
yeah Thank You chair just a very short
one it's actually I've read the report
and obviously it's not the best reading
and I commend mr. Leslie really wanted
to say they sort of record for the
bluntness and the clarity and the
expertise and the freshness that you
brought there to make even a non
financial person understand that the
magnitude of the situation so it is
sorted to say and that to you directly
mr. Leslie said Thank You councillor
sizzle councillor scheudle yeah it's
just getting there again technology
Thank You chairman one thing that this
is the 2d with the the forecasting one
thing that would be useful in terms of
perspective is if we could have a review
of the last quarter and how that
compares with yeah
obviously I hope that can come to
Council next time but how that compares
to last year so we did we have a year to
date so we can look at what last year
was like and what this year's being like
along with the new government money the
grants coming in so we've got an
understanding of where we are at this
present time whether that could come to
Council next time mr. Leslie thank you
sir
within there one of them is a review of
last year's and obviously the answer and
report will help with that what we can
look at where we had some under spins
and see if they're historic and if
indeed we can make some savings along
those lines absolutely see what's
achievable with nice timeframes and be
part of our work will be to look at
actually historic spend current spends
and how we're tracking and as well so is
something we'll be working on and we can
look at presentation with that regard
going forward but that of course is a is
a key part of budget monitoring yeah
Thank You chairman well I think mr. les
has answered all the questions and and
it's clear from what the members have
been saying that they've they've read
this report we are where we are with
this just to reiterate what councilor
stem said earlier but I would just pick
up on one thing that councilor Swain
said you know to reduce non-statutory
services actually changes the way the
district looks like and I think that
members we should do everything we
possibly can to not do that and that we
find ways of making this budget work now
the mhm CLG have said that they will
give us more funding so hopefully that
will be basically to cover around losses
which we understand could be income so
hopefully when we get to the 6th of
August we'll have a better understanding
of exactly where we are but I've got
every faith on in the directors to get
through this get us to the other side so
we can start building back and
replenishing our finances chairman I did
propose the recommendation I think it
did not ask that you put the question
members are you happy to agree this
recommendation sent reclamation we go on
to din right team Kobe 19 reset and
recovery member working group leader on
pages 99 to 102 leader Thank You
chairman I mean this is a pretty
straightforward report clearly we are
going to need a working group chairman
to look at all of the impacts on this it
will of course be reporting back to it
will be were reporting back to Council
in normal ways and as far as the
recommendations of concern chairman with
regards to recommendation one I'd
propose that we agreed that and with
regards to the other recommendation
chairman are but I would propose that we
added an additional recommendation of
three which is basically a housekeeping
issue but nevertheless I think it needs
to go on in there because this discount
this group is going to do a lot of work
which stretches across all aspects of
Council so Mike my my proposal will be
to add recommendation 3 and I would
propose adding the following words that
following the first meeting of the
working group the terms of reference of
the working group are agreed by council
now my understanding is German that
council meeting on six of all because
this working group will be called
probably in the next week or so they can
look at their terms of reference and
then they can come back and have those
approved by council and if council
aren't happy then they can be adjusted
and of course chairman I'm now gonna go
to the key I'm now going to the
recommendation to chairman and and the
council six member representatives to
the working group chairman and III would
propose chairman in the following
councillors are appointed to the working
group counselors Fluke up fleming
Siddall chana stilts
and counselor Wendy's stamp with my
endorsement chairman thank you though ii
did i've got speakers i just i think we
have the wrong nominations it should be
council amazing counselor stilts kevin
that being the case I obviously miss
miss her chairman what my friend the
leader of the Opposition told me today
and I apologize so chairman I'll
withdraw my previous recommendation and
I the following members I propose of
elected councillor felucca fleming
sidled chana maize and stilts chairman
and I hope that satisfies councilor her
thank you yes thank you chairman and
looking at the list of things for this
some group there's a lot of work then
but I think there's too much work there
particularly when it includes financial
recovery and economic progress or
commercial progress and I would say this
is quite a separate and important
working group in its own so I would I
would prefer this to be to working
groups when dealing with the financial
and economic strategy and the other with
the remaining four items in the list of
terms of reference sorry mr. chairman
the report is very good and I feel that
the recommendations are strong but we
also think that again it's gone into
politics and that some of the
non-aligned members or at least one of
them
members should be considered to sit on
on this group and I'd like to see
counselor Morris in that case it's very
eated to not have people put through
into that because sometimes they were
vocal by I think people have got to give
and I think they should be a full
representation of members of the council
not just a pop I think that's a proposal
a second it is a proposal thank you you
know we've got on the table and what
just being proposed is an amendment of
the names but not to the substantive
little one and little to just of the
name or little three just for the names
so for the time being I'll I'll move on
with the debate with mrs. chana thank
you
Thank You Sherman just having a bit of
technology here and my reports
disappeared off my screen just to say
regarding councilor Swain's point I
actually think the office who wrote the
report has covered that off because it
does state quite clearly there be no
duplication where there may be other
groups and they would feed in to this
body that's being set up
and therefore this body could then be
the coordinating role so I think that
covers off councillor Swain's concerns
in my opinion so can we agree the three
recommendations before we move to the
motion of names which there is a motion
with six times on which was duly
seconded so can we agree that those one
two and three members three tarah will
you put up the names if you've got them
the names of the six people that are
proposed and seconded can you do that
Tara you come you you're mute so I say
so yes just give me a second I'm just
being up on screen okay members this
this again is a motion with six names on
it and if this motion fails we will then
move to an additional motion with
councillor leggins and propose
[Music]
his proposal okay Thank You chairman
thank you mrs. counselor mrs. stills
that's it yeah okay so Tara what's the
question
it's for six times against motion on the
table if this files will then consider
counselor leggins ugly chairman
but members if you could just indicate
for against to abstain starting we've
canceled about please for you cancer
passenger sorry miss Beale let's go
yeah cancer Bell against Thank You
Katherine voice sorry I cast voice your
favor
abstain Thank You counsel mrs. Jenna or
Torah for he cats the darn ball Thank
You cats Edwards against you can
swimming or
[Music]
Katsav Luca for thank you
that's the Harker or cats the hurt and
just to confirm we aren't voting for
these six names yes yes so I cannot
support relinquishment of an independent
place so I am for this resolution Thank
You councillor helm for cancer home oh
that's the Jarvis poor that's the keys
for key council nagging again space
Tatara much cats amaze against you can't
some morning for you cats amorous not
politically balanced so against cancer
Sydal for schemes against that's a step
against that's the stilts
for mrs. Thompson or children the result
of that vote is 18 for 7 against a one
abstention
is that that is therefore carried we
could now move on to agenda item 15
council Constitution addition to the
officer scheme of delegation pavement
license is found on pages 103 to 104
leader Thank You chairman this is fairly
straightforward members and it comes out
of the business and planning at 2020 and
then deed first to act swiftly to allow
our businesses to trade outside of their
premises for mitigation for the
implications and the kovat crisis and
chairman my proposal would be that we
agree recommendation one and that I
think the recommendation to isn't quite
right because the the actual business
and planning at sets of fear I think a
maximum of a hundred pounds but I think
it's our intention that we're actually
saying up to a hundred pounds in report
but I would like some clarity in a
recommendation chairman that it should
be 50 pounds so we might need to just
add a line that FIFA pavement license
applications will be set at a hundred
pounds but modern district outs will
fear be fifty pounds I'm sure mr. Holmes
will help me out with some wording
exactly on that and and Chairman I would
also propose you know clearly we've got
to act incredibly swiftly over this but
I would propose to have another third
recommendation is a deed that says that
board members will be consulted with
during the process German science I
think it's important because they will
have certain information which might not
be obviously available to officers when
they decide so officers will be
determining but that will be dealt with
in consultation with more members and
I'm sure the board members in modern to
be particularly the harsh treated be
very pleased to hear that thinking thank
you chairman yes I think the soliciting
is for little too the recommendations
that the fever payment license
application be said if the bill allows
us to charge up to 100 it wasn't our
intention to go to the maximum so if we
could just change that to 50 pounds and
that would that would be appropriate
thank you thank you
and I think councilor swine compromise
all right yes Thank You mr. chairman I
just would like a bit of clarity perhaps
mr. Holmes bill actually says states
that it is a seven day consultation from
the day of the application sorry the day
after the application the report though
mentions that there is a further seven
day
to determine the application I'm not
sure that there is I think this is
really really a quick turnaround and
you've got seven days after the one day
after you've received the application
can you just confirm that for me please
yes a grass mr. Lee to come back because
he's actually drafted this I'm you're
right there is there are two stages
they're still incredibly tight even at
even at 14 days but mr. Lee can you just
explain the difference between the two
periods please yes thank you
Thank You chairman um there is a
statutory period which is the
consultation period and then once again
we do have a statute in relation to
termination so it's a 14 days in
totality but that is obviously different
to either work laughter you must be able
to make an informed judgment on the
determination of any application we need
to have received all the information and
be able to fully assess it and take a
into account I hope that's clarified the
matter yeah that is just isn't what the
bill says so um yeah okay I don't know
where you've got the statutory
allocation for the further seven days
I'm really concerned that there is a lot
of work to do within a seven day period
thank thank chair happy to just double
refresh myself with the bill right now
and just double check but that's my
understanding there's a period you know
it's two periods but I will get back
this provision applies throughout the
district
this is general for the district policy
don't you yes
sorry chairman yet yes I'll again just
check mr. Lai obviously we'd be had a
much greater focus around Baldwin High
Street in terms of allowing the trading
to there but I believe it does apply and
there are may be other parts of the
district where it will also be suitable
to put outside training so I believe yes
we can cover the district through
Chairman yeah that is correct it relates
to any business premises within the
district it's not just within a high
street or a urban center obviously the
nature of these uses are normally in
those locations but yes that is correct
Thank You councillor none thank you
thank you very much can I thank the
leader for agreeing to involve ward
members in this in this process as far
as modern high street is concerned that
was very welcomed by myself and
councillor Mays and it's a healthy move
away from the credence that's been put
by an unelected business board in terms
of high street issues thus far so I'm
very grateful for that
can I suggest that because speed is of
the essence that the officer leading on
this emails the ward members as and when
decisions are needed so that we can
arrive at us with conclusion thank you
Thank You councillor none councilor
laggin Thank You care just just the one
point because Mr Le's I said most of the
locations are in the High Street safety
concerned with social distancing which
is one point but the second is why don't
we just waive the fee or charge a
nominal start because the rate and
reinvigorate the high streets and the
traders who have suffered tremendously
through the Kovach 19 pandemic so I
think 50 quid is still too much let's
support the hell out of these people and
let them have it for nothing
thank you Thank You councillor legen
councillor Bell
Thank You mr. chairman yes sir God likes
we're co-counsel on in
thinking leader for rum saying that
world members should be involved in
decisions however having a great deal
experienced a great deal of experience
on this issue where I live previously
and with issues we're currently
experiencing and burn and where people
feel they can put chairs and tables out
anyway
there are lots and lots of issues
involved with this there's antisocial
behavior there's obstruction there's
social distancing and I really would
like this I really think this is
important enough to go through licensing
I don't realize that that might need to
delays I appreciate that we do need to
stimulate business and support business
recovery but there is a potential can of
worms involved with this and I do think
we need to think very very carefully
before making snap decisions thank you
Thank You chair now I just wanted to
emphasize that speed is of the essence
here so if we could shorten it down as
much as possible you frozen I think
counsel Fleming here with us Sarah
Rudolph's counsel Fleming I mean I just
checked them oh she is still shown as
being their chairman may just be a bad
connection
okay right bolt that concludes the
speakers on this leader would you like
to come back so much yeah Thank You
chairman I mean obviously we need to
move this forward very very quickly so
we can discharge our obligations under
the business and plan in act 2020 so
chairman I'm glad that my third
recommendation has been well received as
far as the comments made by counsel
Abell obviously she'll be involved with
this using earnings so if she's got any
Pacific issues there she can take them
out in the offices I do agree chairman
that once we start this process we will
have a bit more control over what goes
on on our pavement that's because I
agree with councillor bill it does seem
to be a bit of
free fall out there in some places so
Cham lad I propose that with additional
recommendation we agree all three thank
you and thank you
members I have councillor Swain with a
question I think councillor swaying you
wanted us question Devon yes to the
leader and with reference to your
response to a member of the public on
2nd of July in relation to the council's
position on Brad won't be despread
missed your statement on the status of
the LDP with ignores worse the council
may choose to now advise that it no
longer supports the new station in
Beckett's by emotion for example and so
on I wanted to ask was this text agreed
with with mr. Crouch who subsequently
rejected a motion by me along those very
lines and thank you chairman yeah the
demotion my response on 2nd of July
would have been tested legally it would
be missive of the leader of any council
not to do that because motions are
incredibly important to get right
because they often bring forward some
very important issues with regards to
any other motion that you may have been
brought forward is not up to me as the
leader of the council to decide whether
or not your motion is put to Council
it's up to the the chairman of the
council in consultation with Maanshan
officer and others whether or not to
accept a motion on terms and legality
but I I think I think I can understand
perhaps from what you said very briefly
there but if something's already been
answered then the motion wouldn't come
forward but it's not something I know
the detail of because I'm not aware of
your motion and but I mean clearly if
you're unsure had who how this sort of
works I'm more than happy to meet with
you virtually with the monitoring
officer and the chairman
actually can go through this because
some of the motions you've brought
forward have been very important and
welcome so perhaps we can do that
Thank You councillor Morris with the
Moody in the chamber and amongst the
community obviously it's very negative
and hostile to Brad world but faith is
it time that we revised our statement of
supports abruptly because how can we
trust someone with a nuclear power
station when we can't give them Wi-Fi
okay thanks thanks thanks for the the
question yeah I mean look there is a lot
of disquiet about the the nuclear power
station or the potential nuclear power
station at Brad well how it's going to
be operated we've heard about Hawaii I'm
getting emails all the time particularly
on this subject which are not planning
related but I think I use this
opportunity and I'm grateful for it
because it allows me to make a answer
the question then make a statement to
Council I mean I've drafted a letter to
Alok Sharma who's the business energy
and industrial strategy secretary
regarding the future ownership and
shareholding the bread will be stroked
cgn and asking him to explain how
they're going to safeguard the operating
of this power station should it go ahead
in in the future now and I'm just I was
writing to him as a member of the
Council if members wish me to write on
their behalf of the whole council that
if you'd like to email me then I can you
know I can add that to it you know I can
go out on behalf of the council rather
and with regards to your your-your-your
other question I mean that was answered
in some depth through I believe the
question from Judy Lee to change the LDP
would be a long process would be a very
very long process and it's up to members
if they want to
whether you know whether it should you
know whether that's what we want to do
but we will be starting a review of the
should be we will be starting a review
of the LDP shortly and that will be one
of the things that we will start to
review straightaway Thank You chairman
I'd like to ask a question of the leader
please on enforcement planning
enforcement now following an informal
planning meeting earlier this week it
became apparent to me that this council
carries some 5-hundred enforcement cases
in some cases officers are having a
workload of over 200 200 cases now I
don't think that this is sustainable
first of all is the leader happy with
this situation and if not what can he do
to alleviate it thank you
so okay so I think anybody that knows me
particularly from Southeast area
planning committee will know planning
enforcement has been on my radar ever
since I've been a member of this council
some nine years and it's always
concerned me the number of cases that's
on the enforcement list how quickly
they're dealt with and how quickly
they're satisfied southeast area
planning committee has held meetings
just to consider enforcement issues in
in that area and in some cases that's
being very very helpful to the officers
but I agree with you I'm concerned I
mean I'm not you know I'm not going to
criticize anybody we know the list has
been greatly good has been growing for
quite some time but I think for us to
properly understand this I think it
would be very useful council heard that
in if you meet me in your capacity as
the chairman of central planning
along with the chairman of the southeast
planning and Northwest planning I
suggest we meet with mr. Holmes to
review the list with a liddy intention
of bringing a report back to Council
because I believe your son sustained all
we need to understand it and of course
if we do that it may well be that you
know the local area planning committees
might feel as though you know we need to
ask the resources department to see if
they could for example resource and an
additional fixed term contract employee
to try and get into this list I've been
trying to do it for years but we do have
to understand as well that over the last
four or five months there has been you
know the circumstances have been that we
can't send the enforcement team out into
the community so and I think there has
been an increase in enforcement cases as
well June during the Copa dices so
that's what I'm saying that I'm going to
do and I'll do that as quickly as
possible counselor thank you figure
question thank you
and councillor Logan thank you just a
question so they made a place it's to do
with the review of the LDP there's a
couple of points kind of questions
please leader one has the LDP ever been
reviewed since it was approved by the
secretary of state is your other
question connected to the old appeal
I'll answer the first question first
because that's quite straightforward so
with an LD P there's after after her DP
was adopted legislation changed or
planning or changed or guard guidance
which said you had to review it every
five years so we're we're fast
approaching that so the answer to the
question is we do continuously review it
in-house but we have a statutory
obligation to review and that will be
starting soon and that will involve
members like I don't know any more than
that really but we have a statutory
obligation and that will be starting
soon because we have to satisfy the
housing minister that is what we're
doing
and thank you as this the [ __ ] you can
give leveraged off that point anyway the
second point is you mentioned earlier
we're going to be undertaking this to
shortly can we get some dates around
these these statements because we've
also mentioned in earlier on that it's a
long process how long's a piece of
string if we wanted to review it now so
for members to be able to make an
informed decision and to make an
interpretation about whether okay so
council leg and I think I've got I've
got your question and it's always good
to have a bit of background and
everything else it gives me a chance to
formulate an answer but this is a pretty
straightforward one really because my my
my understanding is that you know our
our our plan was when our plan was
adopted there'll be a five-year cycle
through to where we start again with the
review now I'm quite happy to for mr.
Lee to to write you by email to answer
the question but my understanding is we
have to do the review at five years that
isn't a far away we let them start it
and and members will be involved Thank
You mr. Lee yeah councillor Chandler
Thank You chairman I wasn't going to be
asking a question but I am now in light
of the leaders response to a previous
question and no disrespect of the leader
what he said but it does relate to the
question posed about from counsel heard
regarding enforcement does the lead
consumes that I know he's agreed to a
meeting but would this not be an item
before the chairman of planning
committees meetings bearing in mind that
body does exist and with those meetings
are noted so everyone can see the
outcome of that and I asked that
question and also would it through that
body be a timely thing to consider
actually bearing in mind the success
southeast had of holding specific
enforcement meetings
think northwest did too but central
chose to actually do it as part of their
planning committee meeting to review
that and perhaps have a consistency
amongst the three committee areas in
having meetings to look at enforcement
matters as a one-off during the day time
when officers may be more present
although obviously equally with digital
now it's what we're all boss or
available yeah okay councillor chana you
you know my feelings about enforcement
and and everything we've tried to do at
southeast and I think we've actually
done a pretty good job in some areas
look the the leader of the Opposition
I'll actually go back over previously
you know he has got a concern and it's
up to me you know to say right this is
what we're going to do but I agree
you know the planning committee chairs
fallen would also be very very good so
what I'm going to say councillor chana
is is I'm I'm going to speak to the
director of a service delivery after
this meeting and I'll between us we will
decide whether Monaco's to the planning
committee chairs meeting or we have a
separate meeting but I think the most
important thing is is that there is a
meeting is held quickly and if on August
6th I think it is because he's starting
to get out of control but I will check
the best way to go councillor chana and
and we will do this very very quickly
thank you that concludes questions to
the leader we move on to agenda item 17
business by special circumstances I had
none we move on to agenda item 18
exclusion of the public and press and
can I have a seconder for the following
proposes chairman could I just make one
point on that please chairman point on
what in relation to the paragraph
numbers and for schedule twelve could
could and paragraph five be added as
well that's when in relation to legal
professional privilege paragraphs three
which is already down and
five chairman para five horrified yes
can I have a second the following motion
section 184 Local Government Act 1972
that the public impressed be excluded
from the meeting during the
consideration of the following item the
business only grant it on the grounds
that involves the lightly disclosure of
exempt from information as defined in
paragraph three and five of part one of
schedule 12a to the act and that this
satisfies the public interest test